for all you wordle fans out there you  can try your luck at a travel version  take on it called air portal one of the  engineers at scott's cheap fight saw the  trend on wordle taking off creating a  brain-teasing marketing tool for the  company testing people's knowledge on  flight codes now these are the iata  codes the three letter airport codes  universally known worldwide when  referring to an airport ours is las well  every day there is a new puzzle three  letters and you do your best to guess  what the code is  we really love this it's a fun kind of  you have six tries to figure out what  this code might be  and for folks who are traveling it's a  way to kind of think about where you  want to go next fantasizing where you  want to go next you know find myself  constantly putting in fco for rome or  nxp for milan we do have the link to the  air portal game on our website head to  eight news now dot com